benvenuti alla decima edizione degli
hunger games questo ragazzi e il decimo
video su gli hunger games che porto per
l'edizione della mentalità 9 secondi 25
anni iniziò nella memoria però siccome
non so se ci arriva 25 video di questo
show un'edizione della memoria ogni
dieci anni
l'edizione della memoria la facciamo un
po particolare questi andreini sono un
po particolari perché le squadre di oggi
vediamo se riuscite a capire che cosa
sono particolari queste squadre dai loro
componenti partiamo con i presentarveli
distretto no goku e it distretto 2 bart
simpson e action distretto 3 freddi e
deadpool distretto 4 light yagami e chi
rito che sono nella stessa posa 105
thanos e super meat boy distretto 6
stephen universe è suns distretto 7 pari
j e più di pai distretto 8 altri
spaccatutto fine jake distretto 9 elsa e
jason distretto 10 spider man has lander
nel distretto di ciric e morti distretto
12 pt cat
avete capito la particolarità sono tutti
i personaggi fantascientifici tranne
metti di pai quindi io e ti fai siamo
gli unici esseri umani tutto resto e
cartoni e robe personaggi di
fantascienza le grossi parte ragazzi
sono pronto a morire mentre i tributi
stanno sul podio suona il corno loro
lancio
l'uomo arancio ho letto loro raggio
perché era scritto in arancione l'uomo
arancio l'uomo arancio prende una lancia
all'interno dell'accordo copia quito
fugge goku fugge stime universe esplode
in modo esplosivo e beh come voleva
esplodere uccidendo più di play rick
p.te katniss mi è morto il compagno sono
morti tutti gli esseri umani tranne io
perfetta che strano incredibile fine
jake fugge dalla cornucopia la luce
yagami afferrò una pala lander me
finisce gravemente jason e lo lascia
morire il ps tantissimo sta roba che
siano personaggi di finzione perché
strano vederli combattere tra di loro è
più strano che vede le due persone steve
e io reverse e trafigge freddi ma non
stanno morendo tutti deadpool morti e
chirito attaccano con successo e
uccidono goku esce bart simpson ragazzi
ponendo tutti dura due turni sto hunger
games ragazzi quanti morti dieci quasi
record più di pai pagliaio pita katniss
jason freddi gouache ketchum bart
simpson e uomo snello sono morte metà
persone va bene scrive universe
sorprende morti e lo uccide la madonna e
il sagrato e spacca tutto si tengono per
mano allora sono carini fine j che suns
e light yagami canta la canzone
allegramente ce li vedo ce li vedo
tantissimo ce li vedo deadpool e spider
man raccontano storie su se stessi non
l'altra ecco questa ce la vedo molto di
più
spiderman accolti alla stile universe
perfette sono morti i morti sono morti
morti che battute è incredibile
wow che youtuber di qualità rimangono
una decina di persone ragazzi e neanche
troppe potrei sopravvivere ancora un
altro turno sarebbe fantastico la luce
yagami avvelena la bevanda di chi rito
lei lo beve e muore è morto chirito
sunset anno si divideva perché mi è
morto solo chirito ok valigie ten dalle
ferite di fine j che lo farei
assolutamente sun si chiede a rai
spaccatutto di ucciderlo rifiutava
tenendo suns invita quindi è morto non è
morto nessuno vediamo lo stato un attimo
è vivo e vivo
l'importante che sia vivo quindi de
paula fatto traquillo in tutto questo la
veda il diavolo è il s'avanza c
nettamente sulla mina è morta elsa suns
vogliano ata non è morto tano razzi
spaccatutto canino lago ghiacciato
annega è morto ralf spaccatutto parigi
tende alle ferite di ma porca vacca dai
porti fine già incalzata non è altri da
il procedere sto quasi in finale ai
ragazzi quasi ce la posso fare se
resiste ancora un turno sono in finale
spiderman it e laica gavi litigano la
luce yagami uccide trionfalmente
entrambi quindi sono morti loro due
deadpool cade in una fossa e muore
perfetto quello che ha messo meglio
quindi c'è il finale grandissimo
semifinale suns fa vj incredibile super
meat boy è leggermente cops pesci molto
bene io sempre ariete pesci leggeri
yagami andiamo avanti ragazzi uomo ragno
it piscina morta sono morti supera mito
e riceve acqua pulita beckham e ricevono
accetta sa si diceva comunità sta vicino
riceve un ottima prova i grandi sponsor
e in da dj bravi bravi san suu kyi della
luce yagami alla fine di utilizzare il
corpo
qua in modo sicuro cosa non ho capito
perché l'ha ucciso come l'ha ucciso
perche il fuoco raggiunge super meat boy
uccidendo la finale incredibile no come
sia morto anche io a il fuoco si
diffonde in tutta l'arena non l'avevo
letto questo al filo utilizza un colpo
d'acqua quindi della serie si è coperto
con il corpo di lei ti agamy il fuoco
uccide supermeet quel forno ha vinto
suns dai ragazzi ero alla fine sono
morto alla fine
porca vacca in fila per una volta sono
in finale il vincitore suns del
distretto 6 browser
secondo posto porco demonio parco porco
demonio porco di pie è morto subito
io sono morto alla fine ti pare proviamo
ancora un'altra simulazione vediamo che
non succede va bene procedere e proviamo
a vedere di nuovo che succede mentre i
tributi stanno su loro podio sono al
corno i texans combattono per una borsa
si arrende si ritira del colpita
combattono per una volta mazza tante
borse quest'arena mai detto chanel coco
trafigge fine jake con un ramo di albero
funge jason trafigge su trafigge super
meat boy nella parte nel posteriore wire
con il tridente lo maragno scatena un
esplosivo scegliendo di universo di
steven a sketch decapitata nus con una
spada c'è ragazzi
wow lavorano insieme tanto quello ha
vinto gli altri games quindi se ne frega
per i paesi distende la caviglia mentre
scappa da elsa bravo più di pai gow uomo
vero deadpool pesca fatto tutto va a
caccia morti uccide it con una falce la
pioggia acida si diversi riversa sulla
rena a sketch non sopravvive vita
ferisce l'uomo ragno e lo lascia sotto
la pioggia per morire la luce yagami
ferisce morti e lo lascia sotto la
pioggia per morire del pulo rifiuta
rifugio di spacca tutto uccidendolo ci
siamo io e jason e non ho ancora letto
ti prego fai e lucida io avrei spinge e
jason in uno stagno di pioggia ma viene
trascinato da jason uccidendoli entrambi
alexa su una canzone triste
lipari fiuta ricovero di freddy
uccidendolo dopo ferisce katniss e la la
sua sotto la pietà sono morti in mille
14 colpi di cannone record cioè se nella
prima partita vi sembravano tanti qua 14
incredibile fine jake bart simpson chi
mito super meat boy stephen juni vastano
sit l'uomo ragno morti tutti i morti
resto accaduto fari james jason freddi e
katniss spiri mai se non vinci ti
ammazzo vita scatena un esplosivo
uccidendo a sketch deadpool kebab e
hunger games durati due minuti e il
sapri pais le ndrine goku rintraccia
incidono pita ci sono alleati per
ucciderlo perché la troppo forte ci sta
la cornucopia viene rifornita di cibo
scorte armi memoria delle famiglie dei
tributi conclude capital lander man goku
cerca di fissare un pesce con un
tridente rick devia l'attenzione di più
di baie scappa via
elsa si ferisce rimasti ancora in
quattro ragazzi morti pitt e uomo snello
semifinale riceve dell'acqua pulita elsa
spara una freccia dalla testa di goku pd
poi guarda il cielo notturno è morto
goku essa si interroga sulla sanità
mentale ricche scopre un fiume pd pari a
un esplosivo vai più di un salotto la
pioggia acida si riversa sulla rena no
essa non riesce a trovare rifare muore
riferisce più di paola lascia sotto la
pioggia ma uthayo veramente ma vera ha
vinto ric
il vincitore ricche di stato 11 poi in
finale morto anche lui come me prima
sempre in finale arriviamo poi moriamo
ma come vedi ragazzi terminal edizione
della memoria sono finiti spero che il
video vi sia piaciuto hanno vinto stans
è rick come al solito ragazzi 6 video è
piaciuto al documento mi piace anche
vari social come dotata trascrizione
ricordatevi di iscrivervi al canale
servito vi è piaciuto era come sempre ci
vediamo hanno proseguito la ragazza
[Musica]